[Music]
[Music]
the austro-hungarian Navy was oftentimes
overlooked in history as a meager
attempt of trying to catch up to the
rest of the European powers Howard this
view is an entirely correct as the
Imperial Navy was far from small and at
one point was the seventh largest Navy
in the world plus the technology used on
its ships like radios was far from
outdated and the naval structure based
off of the British Navy was on par with
every other superpower of the early 20th
century so with all this said why people
today don't know much about the
Australian Navy let alone know that
austria-hungary even had a Navy this is
mostly due to the fact that even though
the austro-hungarian Navy was strong in
its own right it was always treated as
an afterthought in the empire this can
be seen through the fact that the Navy
was part of the war ministry which was
controlled by the military as such the
naval budget was very small numbering
only around 18 million crowns in 1899
this was five times less compared to the
Italian naval budget and 30 and a half
times less compared to the British naval
budget Howard this naval budget would
slowly start to increase going into
World War one not only because of the
looming threat of war but also due to
the fact that Archduke Franz Ferdinand
was very keen on having a large and
strong Navy as he saw the benefits such
naval power can bring to the country he
heavily campaigned on the side of the
Navy and ironically it could be said
that without him the impale Navy
wouldn't even be ready for World War one
but the lack of money was far from the
only problem the austro-hungarian Navy
had to face for one the multicultural
nature of the environment that you could
hear eight different languages or more
spoken on any given ship and officers
were required to know at least four of
these languages naturally such structure
didn't always result in the most
smoothest of order executions when he
came to the sailors themself majority of
them in the 19th century came from
Croatia and Italy as they were largely
the only ethnicities in the empire that
had any extensive sailing experience
however this started to change in the
early 20th century when the involvement
of minorities became more prominent
across the Empire and the naval
recruitment and training became more
standardized with this increased
recruitment of different ethnic groups
to avoid any confusion on a ship people
have the same / similar ethnicities
where oftentimes given similar roles so
they could communicate orders more
easily ie Germans Czechs and Slovaks
where Gunners
machinist Hungarians were anti-air and
machine-gun crew Croats and Slovenes
were deckhands and Stoker's etc lastly
probably the most major problem facing
the Australian Navy was in the
construction of its ships at first the
construction was limited due to the lack
of Hungarian parliamentary support who
viewed the Navy as a pointless expensive
waste of money however as an all-out war
started to be more and more inevitable
they backed down with their opposition
but with that another major problem
started to come to light which was the
fact that the double nature of the
monarchy manned that all governmental
industrial spending had to be divided
between the hungarian part and austrian
part 34.4% to sixty five point six
percent respectively with that said the
34.4% still proved problematic for the
navy to spend in hungary as majority of
the austro-hungarian industry was in the
austrian half of the empire and whatever
little industry was in the hungarian
part wasn't up to date to be able to
build the high-tech ships that the
Imperial Navy had designed so the ship
designs had to be altered for the
Hungarian industry to be able to build
the 34.4% of the ships most notable of
these changes was the use of less
powered engines different electrical
wiring different boilers the use of
different screws and bolts etc these
ships would later improve not as
reliable as the ones built in austrian
part of the empire however what was
remarkable was that even du told these
changes the ships built in the Hungarian
part weren't far behind and benchmarks
compared to the austrian ships with all
that said the limited governmental
funding and the division of construction
between the two parts of the empire
resulted in the fact that the
austro-hungarian navy had to very
heavily budget its operations to remain
relevant on the world stage
such budgeting included restricted use
of high class ships lower number of
active operational squadrons building
ships with a lower overall tonnage and
mostly inclusive lower wages compared to
its rivals this budgeting proved to be
quite effective as at the outbreak of
World War one austria-hungary had 110
ships and five submarines with three
extra dreadknots in construction in
comparison the Italian Navy which was
viewed as the main rival of the Imperial
Navy had only hundred and forty-nine
ships with twenty-one submarines and no
boats and active construction and even
though it may be more compared to what
the Imperial Navy had considering how
much of a larger budget
Navy had to work with it wasn't that big
of a difference therefore going into
World War one the austro-hungarian Navy
was far from being a pushover and the
Allies had to seriously consider the
Imperial Navy strength especially when
it came to planning Mediterranean
operations speaking of which when it
came to preparing for World War one the
Imperial Navy had three battle
strategies in mind the first was
conceived prior to the breakup of the
Triple Alliance when Italy was still
considered a viable ally this plan
involved all Hungarian Navy and the
Italian Navy to use Italian bases in
Sicily to block the French but mainly
the British from crossing the
Mediterranean and consequently the Suez
Canal this would mean that Britain would
be cut off from its fast route into the
Eastern colonies and would have to use
the long way around which would
drastically diminish its fighting power
especially when it came to a drawn-out
war however the strategy was far from
foolproof and both the Italian and
Imperial navies had their doubts about
being able to keep the French and
British navies from crossing the
Mediterranean as such the back-up plan
was to use the bases in Sicily to
heavily harass Allied shipping in the
area so that it proved too costly for
the Allies to use those shipping routes
however this entire naval plan fell
through when it became increasingly
clear that Italy wasn't going to follow
through on its promise to the Triple
Alliance as such the second plan of the
Hungarian Navy was to do a preemptive
strike on the main Italian ports and the
Adriatic effectively crippling the
Italian ability to the naval operations
in the area and enabling of the Imperial
Navy to take full control of that part
of the Mediterranean third and also the
most conservative plan of the
austro-hungarian Navy was to use its
vast number of torpedo boats to focus on
the defense of the Adriatic coastline
protecting the valuable ports towns and
shipping all while threatening to attack
with the rest of its Navy at any moment
this way they could keep the much larger
French and Italian Mediterranean navies
in check effectively hindering their
actions in other theatres of the war
when the grade were started in 1914 the
initial neutrality of Italy meant that
the Imperial Navy had to implement their
defensive tactic as they couldn't
execute their preemptive bombardment of
the Italian Adriatic coastline when
Italy finally joined the war in 1915 the
Imperial Navy executed their second
Howard is proved ineffective as their
preemptive strike / not so pre-emptive
as Italy had ample time to prepare for
it with that the Imperial Navy went back
to their defensive strategy which proved
effective because the Allied navies
didn't wanted to risk a full-on naval
battle with them resorting to small
battle missions and bulk aides of
daughter on toast rates this meant that
there were continuous small skirmishes /
battles throughout the Adriatic like the
Battle of those Anto Straits where the
Imperial Navy managed to score a victory
but that battle just as every other
Imperial naval battle didn't result in
any decisive changes so the
austro-hungarian Navy excluding the
submarines was forced to operate only in
the Adriatic the stagnation combined
with the dwindling close deployment that
the austro-hungarian Navy didn't go out
with a bang but with a fizzle keeping
the Allied armies at bay in the Adriatic
but remaining largely stagnant till the
end of the war after which it got
divided between the Allies and the newly
formed ego Slavia and then mostly
dismantled for scrap and with that the
austro-hungarian Navy which was able to
hold its own against the Allied navies
got mostly forgotten remaining today
largely as a small footnote when talking
about the austro-hungarian Empire this
video is part of a much larger YouTube
naval history collaboration codenamed
Operation Odysseus involving 17
different history YouTube channels out
of these youtubers potential history and
wartime history have video set in the
20th century just as mine was so check
them out and if you want to see all the
operational Decius videos there's a link
to a playlist down in the description
mean cookie dough also have a youtube
history podcast you can check out and my
name is advisor
see you next time